yesterday Joe Biden leaving Ukraine well
he tripped up the stairs again
[Music]
it's interesting that he's always
tripping up the stairs you know what I
mean most people fall down the stairs
gravity would dictate that you'd usually
fall down but he falls up now there's
obviously something a little wrong with
his gate the way he walks I mean
something because of whatever is going
on is not quite right this keeps
happening okay I don't even mean to make
a big deal about that actually we're
showing you that because I'm mostly
going to be talking about Justin Trudeau
today and then we're getting to a locals
Community Q a but Justin Trudeau fell
the other day too and this one was just
sort of hilarious
I feel like we should have looped that
like 20. I'm just the tree no I fell on
that I Love You Gavin Newsom
[Music]